A few people wrote me to ask about
turning the Mexican wave. Poi, same
time, opposites, inwards or outwards,
above the head, alternating which one's
in front and which one's behind. Facing
you, it's inwards. Facing away, it's
outwards. If I go to the halfway point,
uh, my right's backward, my left is
forwards, and I'm facing that way. I
could look at you, do my inwards Mexican
wave. I could look away and do my
outwards Mexican wave. And I could also
launch that from facing this way where
it's my right forward or my left
backward. Really want to think of that
as a range of motion from the hips to
the sides down the sides that will take
you all the way eventually to po. The
other theme is the rhythm of how many
circles to do as you turn. A lot of
people get stuck on only counting the
bottom of the circles. But if I do that,
watch this. It's one circle. Boom. One
beat. One beat. One beat. If you watch,
you'll notice I'm only doing half a
circle on the far side and a circle and
a half facing the camera. Totally not
symmetrical. Once I have the top of the
circles, I realize, oh, on this side of
my body, it's going top, bottom, top.
It's two ups and one down. On this side,
to make it symmetrical, I need to make
it two bottoms and one top on the other
side. That can make sense if we think of
it this way. It's a bottom there and a
top there. Half a circle on each side.
Half bottom half of the circle, top half
of the circle. To make it symmetrical, I
need to add a full extra loop. Up on
this side, down on that side. Up on this
side, down on that side. Bottom top,
bottom, top, bottom, top, bottom, top,
bottom, top, bottom, top, bottom.
Two ups and one down on this side. Two
downs and one up on that side. That's
where the pattern is symmetrical. That's
what the PO are doing when I'm turning
like this or Mexican wave. One of them
is doing top bottom top while the
other's doing bottom top bottom
brain
brain. That might not be all perfect in
a week of practicing. Uh but eventually
come back to this video every now and
then and it'll all make sense in the
long run.
[Music]